let's bring in kim derek first of all
though um what did you feel when you saw
those images last night
appalled and horrified but i have to say
not completely surprised
the president has been riding up his
base for several days now
he uh has been encouraging people to
pitch up in washington on the day of the
uh the congressional vote
and to demonstrate he did a speech
as did members of his family uh to the
crowds
and he urged them to march on the
capitol what did he think was going to
happen
when they got there they would just sit
around
and um uh you know watch events and then
go quietly home
i mean this was incited there's no
question and it was a
quite terrible scene which will do huge
damage to america's reputation around
the world
i mean in terms of that damage around
the world
you've worked in diplomatic circles for
a long time what is
that damage well you know
we've been seeing there have been scenes
before several times in my career
of crowds protesters mobs
descending on on parliaments
or on presidential offices but not
if i can say this not in in a country
like america
so it is extraordinary and unprecedented
and i think there would have been
jubilation in the kremlin
this morning uh they'll have watched uh
proceedings in beijing and thought
so this is what democracy looks like now
is it um
and all of those countries around the
world that saw america
as a beacon the shining city on the hill
we'll be thinking again i mean
you know this damage can be repaired but
it'll take it'll take a long time
what should the uk be doing now do you
think
um look biden will be
uh inaugurated on the 20th of january
uh his uh with the with the democrats
now having uh
the senate he will get his cabinet his
senior appointments through
i think uh we'll need to build relations
with the bike administration and there's
a way to go there
um i worry about the period between now
the 13 days between now
and the 20th because there's more
opportunities for
the president if he chooses to incite
and rile up his supporters
and obviously the day of the
inauguration is a potential flash point
but you would hope particularly on the
back of that tweet
from a member of the white house on
president's behalf today
that he has realized that this is um
this is not helping him
even if his objective is to run again
in 2024 and to keep his base with him
this isn't helping them i don't think
let's bring in omarosa manigault newman
a former advisor to donald trump thanks
so much for joining us
um you've tweeted this morning uh our
time time for
the 25th amendment um do you think
realistically
that that should be applied to donald
trump over the next two weeks
there is no question that the 25th
amendment should be enacted
and certainly the images from yesterday
is
an indicator that donald trump is unable
to fulfill the responsibilities
and the duties of his office he in fact
earlier that day giving remarks to this
mob encouraged them to storm the capital
to go to the capitol and he said you
can't be weak you have to be forceful
that truly is a threat to this country
donald trump should be removed from
office immediately uh he he said in his
tweet today uh
you know about making america great
again suggesting
uh omarosa that that this is not
finished as far as he is concerned in
terms of
future and future politics do you think
he has any future in american politics
now
well certainly uh watching his rise to
power
in 2015 being there on the front row i
uh would never say never but donald
trump has certainly
um weakened his chances of anyway
getting a majority of americans to vote
for him
but moreover his base will soon see that
donald trump is a threat to everything
that we stand for in this country
and so four years it's a long time
particularly when he's facing
investigations possible jail time
crimes and criminal behavior that will
be investigated
over and over again for the next four
years i certainly don't see
a path for donald trump being president
again but like i said never say never in
american politics
lord derek let's just bring you back in
i mean do you think
british politicians who've worked
closely with trump
uh are damaged at all by by what
happened last night are they
will they be looked back in history and
and have been seen to misjudge
that relationship i think they will try
and move on from it they will try and
claim that they were never that close to
him
and i mean if you look if you look at
policies
uh boris johnson is a very different
place from donald trump on quite a lot
of issues
but there are some things they have said
over the trump presidency
that i think they will um they will now
regret and i think we'll
we'll stick with them uh we we got a bit
too close
to um trump presidency um and we were
we were too uh warm our leaders were too
warm
about trump's performance i mean this
isn't this is the worst
of the things that has happened in the
trump presidency but don't let's forget
his his um his words about
white supremacists being very fine
people in charlottesville
his words about uh american congress
women
of color they should go back to where
they came from
and some of the other events whose
presidency this is part of
a pattern of a president who just does
not follow
the norms of of presidential behavior
and never has really
you say some politicians being too warm
towards him
are there any examples you can give us
well i just
note that while some of our
some other european politicians have
been openly critical
and named the president um uh
in terms of criticizing his denial of
the election outcome
and some of the events since the
election and particularly the events of
last night
um our politicians have tended to
criticize or condemn the events without
without name checking the president and
i understand why they do that look i
i was in government for 40 years and i
spent some of that time as
a press spokesman and i can imagine the
prospects drafting texts for the
um for their ministers that try to avoid
being too explicit
about donald trump's personal
responsibility of what has happened but
look to all of us now sitting outside
government is undeniable
uh omarisa manigault newman
al scardina who we spoke to a little
earlier i don't know if you were able to
see it
talked about what happened last night
about white supremacist which which lord
derek also referred to just there
that he said he felt that what happened
last night was in his words
a culmination of a counter-revolution of
the civil rights act
of the 1960s do you feel about that do
you feel that this is
as significant as that
i i think it is certainly significant
but i also want to just
uh bring you back to just months ago
when
black lives matter protesters were in
washington d.c
and tanks were rolling down pennsylvania
avenue and constitutional avenue
and the show of force from the military
from
capitol police from metropolitan police
was just
unheard of and then to justify that to
yesterday
where there was absolutely no presence a
very minimal
presence it makes african-americans feel
unsafe in this country it makes us feel
as though we are certainly back in the
times where dogs were released on
protesters
and where you couldn't walk down the
street without being harassed
yesterday was a very consequential day
for african-americans in this country
and a day of reckoning
on race for this country as well
do you think that any positives will
come of it omarosa i mean
do you think that it will cause
people in america who perhaps aren't
black and perhaps
haven't realized how bad things have got
for so many black people in america
to sit up and take notice
yesterday even some of my former
colleagues in the white house who
i remain in touch with had to
acknowledge
that um that this administration failed
on racial reckoning in fact inflamed
the divisions and so when you ask about
one positive note
i guess the positive note is that we can
count down the 13 days left in donald
trump's
administration and call it what it is
donald trump will go down
as the most racist president in the
history of our nation
great to talk to you both omarosa
manigault newman
and also lord kim darrick thank you both
very much for joining us